one of our more gruesome videos
was trying to dissolve chickens legs
which I bought at the butcher in
hydrofluoric acid and comparing it with
hydrochloric acid and sulfuric acid and
the hydrofluoric acid HF made the
chicken leg look deader than I've ever
seen anything
and so we thought that was all there was
and then I got an email from a guy
called Mark
who said we shouldn't have used
concentrated sulfuric acid you need
sulfuric acid with water in it and the
chicken legs would have dissolved much
better this email prompted some quite
interesting and possibly even more
gruesome experiments so what we thought
is we would compare concentrated
sulfuric acid
and diluted sulfuric acid with chicken
legs in them but since we had a whole
packet of chicken legs Neil wanted to do
a third acid one that he knew would work
and he chose chromic acid a mixture of
dichromate
and conch sulfuric acid which is what
used to be used for cleaning glassware
removes almost all stains Neil set up a
strange device with three chicken legs
hanging on it
with a spare chicken leg as a control on
the bench and then he lowered the
chicken legs into the beakers of the
acid
[Music]
now what happened was that two of them
the dilute sulfuric acid and the chromic
acid started bubbling the chromic acid
when you put in the chicken leg started
to go green this would be expected
because when chromic acid reacts it
forms a green chromium III salt you may
have seen a similar thing in the fire
when I set off the fire alarm at the
University
[Music]
the orange sample went green
but there were violent reactions well
violent it was babbling away at that
point Brady and Neil thought perhaps
they should measure the temperature and
they found that the dilute sulfuric acid
and the chromic acid were both more than
80 degrees Celsius because
diluting sulfuric acid releases a lot of
heat
was the concentrated sulfuric acid was
still close to room temperature why is
that Professor I thought the
concentrated acid would be more powerful
well it may be more powerful but when
you add water to the sulfuric acid
the there is if you like a an
interaction which releases heat the
water helps the sulfuric acid to ionize
into h plus and hso4 minus in the pure
concentrated sulfuric acid there is
probably less ionization in fact Mark
claims that you can put your hand in
self-concentrated sulfuric acid without
harming it as long as you weren't
sweating but I didn't well I wouldn't
try and I wouldn't let Neil try either
it causes the sulfuric acid to
dissociate
and it needs to dissociate before it can
attack
the chicken legs and if you were trying
to dissolve a whole body which had
if you were trying to dissolve a whole
body which of course has blood and a lot
of water in it it probably supplies its
own
dilute sulfuric acid there was quite a
famous murderer John Hague
who dissolved his victims
in concentrated sulfuric acid
but was eventually caught when he
murdered a really fat woman
and her fat did not dissolve properly
and bits of fat were found lying around
where he threw away the residues from
the sulfuric acid kneel and Brady
decided to leave everything overnight
the next day
they took out the samples of course the
acids were all cold by then there wasn't
really all that much difference between
the concentrated sulfuric acid and the
more diluted both chicken legs had lost
quite a bit of meat and they'd gone a
brown color which really didn't look
very appetizing not dead like HF but
still
pretty young but the chromic acid had
really suffered a lot more and clearly
chromic acid is much more efficient at
destroying flesh now I'm not sure that
these experiments prove very much except
probably
that Neil knows a lot more about these
things than the rest of us and his
choice of acid for dissolving chicken
legs was much better than mine or my
correspondence Mark when Neil started
clearing up
he decided he ought to neutralize the
chicken legs
and so he put the chicken legs in a
solution of sodium carbonate
so there was more fizzing because the
acid left on the chicken was now
releasing carbon dioxide from the sodium
carbonate
but still look quite exciting fizzing
chicken legs
[Music]
foreign